the uk vaccination program had what you
might call a
mixed weekend on saturday it recorded a
new high
well above the required rate we need to
meet that
target of 15 million vaccination offers
by mid-february but on sunday the daily
rate fell to its lowest point
since here almost a week ago so will we
meet that target
ministers have always said the crucial
factor is supply
that they keep any data about supply top
secret
the only official statistics we've had
are these
the ones accidentally published by the
scottish government
but from them we got a hugely
encouraging picture
this extrapolation which is not official
i should say it's just one that i made
it suggests that when the uk will get to
its deadline on 20th february
each 15th of february it should have 20
million doses
easily enough to meet the target the
only thing is that in practice
things haven't worked out like that this
blue area
is actual doses and you can see we're
below the line projected by the scottish
government
now the reason i understand is very
simple the big pharmaceutical companies
aren't able to come up with enough doses
since this projection was published
pfizer and astrazeneca
have both had to slow production and
while it does seem
we're capable of doing a lot more if we
have the vaccines
we can't put them in people's arms so
what does that gap mean for the target
well one big clue lies in these figures
for yorkshire which were given to mps
last week
according to this yorkshire should get
000 doses last week 300 000 this week
350 000 next week and 250 000
the week after now these figures are not
confirmed at all
but i have spoken to sources who tell me
they're pretty accurate
and the important thing about these is
that because the vaccine is assigned on
the basis of population
you can take these numbers and work out
what the whole uk is going to get
and that's what we've got here
this yellow line which with the week's
lag added so that you know they can
actually get the supply
out to people shows what the yorkshire
figures suggest
the whole uk population should
get and now you see on this projection
when the government meets its deadline
it's not getting
20 million doses it's getting 14
and a half million that's just enough to
meet that 15 million target
but only because not everyone will take
up their vaccine offer
you can see why on this matt hancock
says supply
is tight but what can ministers do
short of making it themselves there's
honestly not a lot
we are all counting on the
pharmaceutical companies delivering
and as the eu's found out recently that
is not something that can be guaranteed